SAM DUTTON: These days,
more and more of us
are experiencing the web
on phones and tablets.
But the mobile web isn't
just same old thing,
different devices.
What we do on the
web is changing.
In particular, we're using
video on the go more and more
for entertainment, information,
and real time communication.
People love video.
It's estimate that within
three years, more than 80%
of traffic on the
internet will be video.
But video takes bandwidth
and doesn't always
work the same way
across every platform.
I'm going to show you how to add
video capability to your site
and ensure the best
experience on any device.
So how do you get
video on a web page?
How do you do that on mobile?
Well, for that we have
the video element.
And the video element is
a thing of simple beauty.
Download, decode, and play
video in a few lines of code.
And because it's just
another DOM element,
you can do things like change
opacity, add CSS filters,
and put other elements on top.
The video element is supported
by over 85% of browsers,
including all current browsers
on desktop and mobile.
It's simple to set a
start time and an end
time for video playback by
adding a fragment to the source
URL.
This is useful for
providing multiple views
on the same video, and
potentially reducing
download requirements.
Here we're playing the video
from five to 10 seconds only.
Now, to ensure your site
can serve segments of video
without having to
download the whole file,
make sure Range Requests are
supported on your web server.
Range requests are enabled
by default on most servers,
but some hosting services
may turn them off.
You can check with
the cURL utility.
This should return a response
that includes an Accept-Ranges
byte header just like this.
OK.
Now, that simple
example is nice,
but it only points
to one video source.
And of course, not all browsers
support the same video formats.
The good news is that MP4 and
WebM cover all modern browsers,
including all mobile browsers.
Use the source element
to enable browsers
to choose from multiple
available formats.
You can specify video sources
in order of preference.
Here, Chrome chooses the WebM
file, Safari chooses the MP4.
No server-side detection
or JavaScript required.
A quick word about
the video formats.
MP4 and WebM are
container formats.
You could think of these
a bit like zip files,
containing both audio
and video components.
Most commonly, MP4 stores audio
using AAC compression and video
using H.264.
WebM uses VP8 video and Vorbis
audio, or more recently, VP9
and Opus.
Now, specifying video
types on the source element
can really improve performance.
Let's take a look
at network activity
for the current example.
You'll see that
Safari has to download
a little bit of metadata
from the WebM file
to sniff the format
to check if it's
supported, which it is not.
Now, that requires
one more request,
a little more processing,
a little more latency,
which is not good anywhere,
particularly on mobile.
Adding a type attribute
to a source element
enables the browser to select
a video source without having
to download any of
the video to check.
Let's see how that looks from
the Safari Web Inspector.
Excellent.
As you can see, Safari now
only downloads the MP4.
Now here's another tip for you,
thinking about video types.
You need to make sure
your server reports
the right MIME type.
Otherwise, video source
type checks won't work.
This should be set correctly,
but you may want to check.
Here you can see from
the Chrome Dev Tools
that video WebM was the type
returned for a WebM video,
just as it should be.
Want to know what formats are
supported by your browser?
Try the video
canPlayType method.
Now, in this
example, canPlayType
returns an empty string
for the nonsense value Foo,
maybe for video
WebM, and probably
for the full container
codec combination.
Want to know which source
was actually chosen?
Use the current source property.
While we're there, let's get
the actual height and width
of the video using video
width and video height.
These sizes might be
different from the dimensions
of the video element
as it's displayed
on the page in the same way
that images can be displayed
larger or smaller than
their original size.
Notice here that the video
dimensions as sized by CSS
are different from the
original height and width.
On the subject of
size, a simple point.
Don't use videos
that are too big.
Make sure to save
videos with a frame
size appropriate
to the platform.
Here's one I got wrong.
I saved a video screencast
at its original size, 1080
by 1920 pixels.
It's enormous.
Over five megabytes in file
size, and much bigger in frame
size than it needs
to be for mobile.
Now, my first impulse
was just to tweak
the size of the video element.
But that's a bad idea.
Much better to save
the video close
to display size in
the first place.
Here's the same,
360 by 640 pixels.
It looks great and it's less
than a third of the file size.
Now, if it makes sense,
you can use media queries
to choose a different
video depending
on the viewport dimensions.
With a bigger viewport,
you get the bigger video.
This one's 1280 by 720 pixels.
Looks good.
On a phone, you get
the smaller video.
As you can see, this
one's 480 by 270 pixels.
Also looks good.
And again, it's about a
third of the file size.
Working with
display size in CSS,
a simple technique for video
is to specify a width and a max
width.
That way you get
a preferred size,
but the video never
overflows its container.
Don't specify a height.
The browser will work
that out automatically.
That way you'll keep
the right aspect ratio.
It's much easier and less
error prone than trying
to calculate it manually.
There are similar techniques
available for embedded YouTube
videos.
Compare the unresponsive
sample here--
bleh-- with the
responsive version.
Nice.
All done with some pretty
simple HTML and CSS.
Now, given that mobile usage is
growing at an explosive rate,
it's crucial to think about
how video works differently
on mobile devices versus
desktop or laptop.
In particular,
device orientation
is not an issue on desktop
monitors or laptops,
but is hugely important
when considering web page
design for mobile and tablets.
Safari on iPhone does a good job
of switching between portrait
and landscape orientation.
Device orientation on an
iPad and Chrome on Android
is different, because
video is played back right
in the video
element on the page.
For example, without
any customization,
a video playing on an iPad
in landscape orientation
looks like this.
On Android and
desktop browsers, you
can use the JavaScript
full screen API.
In this example, there's
a thumbnail image
for each of two videos.
You can tap on either to
play back full screen.
And that's a nice way to
include video in a page
without the user having to
download the video until they
want to play it.
Thinking about what
does and doesn't work,
you need to consider your
users who have difficulty
with vision or hearing.
Or who speak a
different language.
Accessibility, it
isn't just a feature.
And thankfully, it's really easy
to make media more accessible
by adding a track element.
The source of a
track element points
to a file consisting of timed
cues in plain text like this.
The format is called WebVTT.
Track is now supported by all
modern browsers on desktop
and mobile, so make
the most of it.
You can use tracks to add
descriptions and captions.
And the track element is
also great for subtitles.
And finally, to give your
users a better experience,
don't forget the humble
poster attribute.
The poster attribute
points to an image
to be displayed in place of
a video before it's loaded.
Including a poster gives viewers
a meaningful idea of content
without having to download
any video or start playback.
Without a poster, nah.
And with one, nice.
The only downside is
that using a poster image
incurs an additional
file request, which
consumes a little
bit of bandwidth
and requires rendering.
So that's it.
But there is one more
really amazing thing
you can do with video on mobile.
You can now make video
calls using WebRTC.
That's real time
communication in the browser.
So I can speak to
my friend Matt.
Hey, Matt.
MATT: Hey, Sam.
SAM DUTTON: How's it going?
You're in Hawaii?
So thanks for watching.
If you follow the
suggestions here
you'll be able to
create and use videos
that work well
across every device.
To find out more, take
a look at our guidance
on Web Fundamentals.
See you there.